the jurogan experience
what is stopping particularly
uh people from the left including
intellectuals
from recognizing the differences that
there are differences
in people that follow the
the peaceful version of the religion and
then
people that follow the more radical
version of the religion that wants to
convert people like
what what what is stopping them from
recognizing that this is an issue
because
it's it's almost like an agreed upon
reluctance to discuss it
to acknowledge it and to automatically
classify any discussion of it
as islamophobic and that i've seen this
labeled
this this label put on you
that you are islamophobic yeah
so the term islamophobia is obviously
very much
a western time it's an opportunity
opportunistic time
the west has gone woke and they
they feel
an intense regret for some of the things
that were done
by the ancestors and so you have names
like
homophobia
sexism and so on and islamophobia
is i would say a time that is put right
in there to exploit that situation it's
it's uh
in my the way i see it's it's an
artificial term
but let's set that aside and let's see
why it is that western
leaders go along with
the assertion that islam is a religion
of peace there's nothing to see here
it's just a small group of people who
have lost their way and they would have
been violent anyway
but in in general islam is a religion of
peace
number one a lot of leaders
contemporary western leaders they
don't know much about religion even
their own
and they don't want to i mean you could
find out
you could be ignorant of something pick
up a few books and just find out
i think number two there is a sense
that because the west is a really
powerful way it matters
economically powerful more powerful than
any islamic country
militarily more powerful diplomatically
more powerful
there is almost that parent child
relationship where
it is we'll just them let them come
along they'll grow up they'll come to
our way of seeing things
if they want to believe that islam is a
religion of peace
let's let's say it's a long let's come
let's do it along with them
with some people i think that is the
case
and then along came isis and they saw
that you couldn't do that and
you are now dealing with people who
truly believe
and i think it was a matter of time
before people in washington and berlin
and london and so on thought
wait a second it's not only that they
believe it it is in the quran
it's in the hadith it's in the history
of islam we better do something about
that
that's when you start to see a shift
in how
the confrontation or the the clash
of values is approached the latest
example if you
let me is the president of france
in france for the last 20 30 40 years
they were saying there's nothing to see
here
islam has evolved it's just like
christianity it's either a religion of
peace
or it's irrelevant altogether all
religions are going to go away
we're we are we're now living in the
past religion age
in 2021 there is a law right now
that has gone through the lower house of
france and it is
being debated in the senate where
they're talking about
in if that law gets passed then
muslims who are accused of trying
to separate their communities from the
rest of
france along religious lines
are going to be stopped by that law
there will be no more homeschooling
they will be told the values of the
republic
prevail anywhere that is a clash between
islamic values and values of the
republic
the values of the republic prevail and
he is saying if that law passes
that's all going to be enforced think
about that
how would they possibly enforce that
look i'm just as curious as you are
they've
they've also banned hijabs on the beach
too right haven't they done that
i get a mixed story about is it the
hijab or the burka
so it's an attack there are attires
where you can take a scarf and cover
your head
i guess that's not banned anywhere
there's no debate about that
but there's something about the thing
that covers your face
and there's been a lot of debate in
europe
about that and part of the
some of the participants of that debate
are saying we're not talking about
religion here it's all about security we
need to see everybody's face
well now everyone wears a mask
it's all out the window because of covet
because of covet and there are other
things that are out of the window
because of covet because
you just asked me how are they going to
enforce those rules
of stopping muslims from separating
themselves from
the rest of society through the
associations
through their schools through everything
that they do that make them say we don't
want to have anything to do with
france even though physically they're in
france right i think they're going to
use some of the measures
that they applied or some of the laws
that they applied during covet they are
going to assume powers
that all of us thoughts a liberal
society would be very careful with
and now they're not so i guess that's
what they're going to apply they'll be
breaking into people's homes
mosques associations whatever looking
for
islamist materials of dawah that
means the proselytizing and and
and they will try and put a stop to that
they'll try and police
literally what goes into people's minds
and comes out of their mouths
wow that seems very dangerous to me
and kovit made it possible
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience